vous allez mener une vraie vie de de
popstar et puis ça s'est quand même
terminé dans une sérieuse addiction à la
cocaïne
d'accord moi j'adore alors lui il peut
parler des supers nanas qui s'est tapé
et moi on parle de mes problèmes de
drogue et sympa sympa
qui m'ont le bon et John Taylor bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors vous
revenez après 20 ans de silence
discographie ensemble bien sûr il y a eu
des morceaux séparément deux par deux
trois par trois mais c'est la première
fois aujourd'hui depuis 20 ans que le
groupe se reforme complètement et nous
en sommes très heureux merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
si nous sommes réunis c'est pour un
excellent public qui est ici
[Applaudissements]
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
Duranne Duranne a vendu 70 millions
d'albums c'était une véritable Duranne
d'urane Mania à l'époque des deux côtés
de l'Atlantique et comme on a appelé les
Beatles les FAP fort on a appelé les
durannes Duranne les failles fabs voilà
donc c'était vraiment énorme pourquoi ça
s'est arrêté Simon
je crois que c'est un effet de mode il
faut bien voir que avec le temps les
choses évoluent il y a des questions de
mode dans le domaine de la pop pendant
quelques années vous sortez quelque
chose de nouveau et puis ensuite les
choses évoluent changent et puis à ce
moment-là il faut que vous essayez de
vous adopter de vous adapter vous
écrivez de nouvelles chansons vous
fassiez des choses nouvelles il faut pas
avoir peur non plus parce que les médias
peuvent vous faire partir vous faire
peur mais si vous voulez faire une
carrière qui dure et bien il faut
continuer d'écrire des chansons alors
pourquoi ça recommence
au bout de 15 ans on se rend compte que
avec qui on a eu des difficultés avec
lesquels on s'est peut-être disputés au
bout de 15 ans après on a passé au bout
de 15 ans ce qui nous paraissaient les
trou du cul nous paraissent très sympa
tout d'un coup et
on se dit on se rend pas compte de ce
qu'on avait pas meilleur que le trou du
cul vous connaissez alors ce qu'il faut
dire ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
vous avez fêter l'anniversaire des 25
ans de Duran Duran et que vous avez eu
un tel accueil c'était soldats et à des
prix très cher 900 euros la place et
vous vous êtes dit c'est peut-être le
moment d'y retourner finalement ah oui à
ce prix là
qui se présentent assez rarement dans
une vie et si on avait passé cette
occasion il aurait fallu attendre 10 ans
de plus le nom Duranne Duranne vient
d'un personnage de Barbarella le film de
Roger Vadim et c'est très marrant parce
que quand vous avez commencé à jouer à
Birmingham vous jouiez dans un club qui
s'appelait le barbare
bon Barbara c'était un club hyper connu
à Birmingham et c'était quelque chose
qui était particulièrement populaire
pendant la période punk quand on est des
gamins mais un soir effectivement le
film Barbarella est passé à la télé et
on cherchait un nom pour notre groupe et
à l'époque tous les groupes avaient un
nom comme les clashs les Sex Pistols
pédales etc et on s'est dit Duran
Duranne c'est différent et puis ensuite
quand on est venu en France les gens
nous ont dit pourquoi si vous êtes pas
appelé
absolument c'est un super nom durant
durant non mais c'est vrai c'est un truc
tu peux pas tu peux pas l'oublier pour
moi deux durant la même table c'est
beaucoup
alors vous alors vous êtes marié depuis
20 ans avec une femme sublime qui est
une des plus jolies femmes du monde un
mannequin top model des années 80 qui
s'appelle Yasmine parvenez un jour le
magazine Rolling Stones américains vous
a posé la question pourquoi les Rockstar
époustillent des top models et vous avez
répondu parce qu'ils peuvent
c'est et il a ajouté et il a ajouté il a
ajouté c'est la même réponse que la
question pourquoi les chiens se
lèvent-ils les couilles
[Applaudissements]
il m'avait piqué ma ma chute ma blague
parce que quelqu'un
pourquoi vous êtes ouvert une pipe dans
la Maison Blanche la réponse parce que
je pouvais
alors il vous arrive des trucs terribles
Simon vous avez reçu une lettre d'une
fan
qui vous dit ton fils va à l'université
il a 21 ans il va bien et je lui ai
jamais dit que tu étais son père et dans
ces cas-là vous montrez la lettre à
votre à votre femme vous êtes allé lui
apporter effectivement j'ai rien donné
il faut il faut être clair sur les trucs
comme ça mais enfin quand même c'était
disons une surprise une situation assez
curieuse parce que bon c'est une lettre
complètement anonyme d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas si c'est si c'est un canard ou
si c'est la vérité j'en sais rien en
tout cas c'est une belle histoire
alors John vous vous êtes le fondateur
du fondateur du groupe vous aussi vous
êtes sortis avec de très beaux top
models vous allez mener une vraie vie de
popstar et puis ça s'est quand même
terminé dans une sérieuse addiction à la
cocaïne
[Applaudissements]
quel a été le meilleur moment dans votre
vie de popstar
bon quand on a créé le groupe lorsqu'on
était aux États-Unis et tout ce qu'on a
fait pour la première fois la première
fois que vous allez à la télé une fois
que vous allez aux États-Unis la
première fois que vous faites ceci cela
ça c'est des grands moments évidemment
mais bon tout va bien à l'heure actuelle
quel a été le pire moment de cette
époque
le groupe a commencé à éclater dans les
années 80 c'était un peu triste c'est un
peu comme si on se posait que vous êtes
en train de prendre un pain et quelqu'un
retire le bouchon et puis tout autrement
on savait ce qui se passait on sait pas
pourquoi alors comme votre plus grand
tube c'est the replay on va faire une
interview reflex
[Musique]
es
[Applaudissements]
après avoir fait l'amour c'est un
entretien
[Rires]
votre premier réflexe quand vous vous
réveillez le matin
je regarde pour savoir
quand vous rentrez dans une boîte
je me planque dans un coin
DJ votre premier réflexe quand une fille
repousse vos avances
aucune expérience en la matière
votre premier réflexe quand vous montez
sur scène
je crache votre premier réflexe quand
vous arrivez dans une partouze
pareil j'aimerais bien avoir une belle
réponse mais j'ai jamais assisté à une
partouze de ma vie
là-dedans votre premier réflexe quand
vous touchez un gros chèque
votre premier réflexe quand on vous
propose de la drogue
si j'avais il suffit de dire il est là
votre premier réflexe quand on vous dit
que votre dernier album est le meilleur
outil avec la personne qui a commencé la
commission
vous êtes contente
[Applaudissements]
que c'était une tellement bonne idée la
seule chose où je suis restée perplexe
c'est pourquoi 900 euros parce que
c'était une charité ou quoi ça m'étonne
cette histoire moi ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que nous en tout cas les
billets sont pas on les vend pas à ce
prix là alors peut-être que ça faisait
partie d'un package d'un deal où on vous
paye le train l'hôtel et la place durant
du Rhône pour par exemple si vous
habitez en Australie et vous payez
l'avion jusqu'en haut jusqu'en
Angleterre ça fait ça fait assez cher
ensuite
nous on voit pas 900 € quand même faut
pas charger vous êtes content de les
avoir rencontré
[Rires]
on est on est dans la cour des grands
ici et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu